donald trump this week as a sort of
counter-programming effort to the
democratic national convention
is traveling each day to different parts
of the country
yesterday he was in wisconsin today i
believe he's in
i think iowa and maybe arizona um
and yesterday specifically in oshkosh
wisconsin
he showed up uh did a sort of rally-like
event i covered it live
and trump simply collapsed once again
into authoritarian daydreams
authoritarian nightmares really saying
he would seek a
third term as president because his
first
term maybe shouldn't count i guess
because he was spied on as he claims
even though of course that is not the
case
take a look at this insanity and
remember it might be a joke to you and
me
we might see this as obviously the
rantings of a lunatic
but a lot of his followers agree with
this idea
we are going to win four more years
[Applause]
and then after that we'll go for another
four years because
you know what they spied on my campaign
we should get a redo of four years
now obviously it's an insane idea
but trump got this insane idea from some
right-wing commentators who started
floating hey you know listen
trump didn't really get a first term
because they spied on him
and they impeached him and they did the
russia investigation
trump heard the idea so he floats it and
now his followers cheer
and some of them support the idea of a
trump third term now of course trump
will get no third term
nor will he run for one but this is how
wildly authoritarian stuff spreads and
it is spreading
some pundit puts it in trump's brain
trump at some point
manic from the crowd cheering floats it
and then you've got to
start hearing from his followers who say
this guy deserves a third term
because he didn't really get a first one
now everything about this appearance
was disturbing trump was very manic
throughout
uh it actually got so bad that trump
started talking about
trying to win the state of new york in
november
it was so crazy that even fox news had
to cut away
again check it out for republicans you
have to run the whole board
because they start off now we're going
to play for new york with all of the
crime in new york i'm going to play for
new york
that was president trump speaking live
wisconsin and an airplane hangar
calling it a peaceful protest not a
traditional campaign rally really
zeroing in on joe biden saying he's
bossed around
now biden is up 24 in new york right now
trump only has 32 percent support in new
york
there is of course no chance that donald
trump wins
new york trump can certainly win and he
can win re-election
but donald trump is not winning new york
and then trump
absurdly claims that the united states
has coronavirus numbers
that are better than almost all
countries
it's difficult to imagine a less
accurate statement
and then trump says the reason you
haven't heard that
is because the media he points to the
back of the room always the media won't
tell you that
they released it they didn't release it
in china but it came to the united
states and europe 188 all over the world
188 countries all over the world we're
not going to forget it
we're not going to forget it but we're
doing great coming back we're coming
back and our numbers are better than
almost all countries
i will tell you that despite what you
hear look at all of them up there
scott look at all of that fake news it's
unbelievable
unfortunately fox has become fake news
too i don't know what happens to these
people right
do you agree trump even turning on fox
news there which i'm going to talk about
more tomorrow
saying fox is fake news but that that's
optics i care about numbers
trump said we're better than almost any
country on coronavirus
just as a reminder we have the eighth
most cases per capita and the 10th
most deaths per capita out of more than
200 countries and territories
those are the numbers then trump went
back
to his terrible reading of a poorly
written speech
and with 170 000 dead americans from
coronavirus
trump says of joe biden joe was bad on
swine flu take a listen
look at all the fake news isn't that
incredible
there are a lot of it's a lot of fake
news back there scott
at the end of joe biden's eight years as
vice president nearly two million
americans a prime working age had
dropped out of the workforce
our factories were stolen our country
was doing lousy
he lost nearly 200 000 manufacturing
jobs
he was by the way a disaster on
swine flu he got a horrible rating
in gallup look at the gallup poll look
at the gallup poll so they call it
h1n1 right do you remember h1 swine flu
h1n1 he calls it by the way
um just to be thorough out of curiosity
i went and looked at the obama biden
approval
on swine flu in 2009 about two-thirds of
the country
approved of the job they did across all
regions of the country
across all levels of concern about swine
flu
so even there trump is wrong on the
facts and of course
is talking about something completely
unrelated to what is pressing now
which is 175 000 really
dead from coronavirus with 55 000
additional likely based on looking at
excess death data
and then strangely donald trump says
chicago is worse than syria
that that's the argument i mean you
probably find it odd
but he said uh chicago is worse than
syria and iraq
the context was of course bragging about
how he militarized our streets
the drawbridge is to prevent hordes of
rioters from
ransacking the city can you believe it
can you believe it 17
officers were injured in chicago they
had a week
a little while ago during a weekend
spree where
78 people were shot and 18
died that's worse than afghanistan which
we're getting out of
that's worse than iraq which we're
almost out of that's worse
than syria which we're out of except we
kept the oil but that's okay we'll have
to talk about that
chicago is worse than syria and iraq
this is all really bad but the seeking
the third
term thing is being weaponized and built
up by his most deranged followers
and this is a presidency that is a
testament
to ignorance the fact that he received
63 million votes in 2016
when running on things like fixing trade
and dealing with china
which he obviously has no clue of it was
a completely
obviously unsuited candidate to the job
but 63 million voted for him and it's a
testament to ignorance
the fact that he failed at everything
during his presidency most acutely
coronavirus
and is back up to polling 42 percent in
the latest gallup presidential tracking
poll
is a testament to ignorance and then
the fact that he floats something as
authoritarian
as a third term while sending
militarized troops to cities
and kneecapping the post office to try
to prevent vote by mail
that is a testament to ignorance and to
people's
own sort of tacit
approval or indifference to the
authoritarianism
they claim to oppose so we're in real
trouble
and we're in trouble as far as the
absentee ballots as well that's what i
want to talk about next
if you are anything like me you probably
aren't thrilled with the idea of going
into
a doctor's office right now and
thankfully there is a
practical and affordable way to take
control of your health
and get personalized care from the
comfort of your home it's a service
called
steady md they're one of our sponsors
you take a quiz
you get matched with a licensed primary
care physician
who understands your health needs you
have a one hour video call with your new
doctor
you establish a meaningful relationship
with them and after that
your doctor is available to you anytime
by text phone or video chat this is not
a random doctor on call each doctor at
steady md
has a limited number of patients so they
actually have time to listen to you
you get the personal attention that you
deserve they can do
almost everything an in-person doctor
can do
perform medical evaluations talk to you
about health concerns
send prescriptions to your home or local
pharmacy
and anything they can't do online
they'll quickly set you up with
an in-person provider to do things like
blood tests as an example
you don't need insurance it's only 99
bucks a month with
no other fees or co-pays there are so
many
practical advantages to using steady md
for primary care
and it's also so much more affordable
go to steadymd.com pacman to take the
free quiz see which doctor is right for
you i took their quiz they matched me
with
a doctor who specializes in my
particular health needs and situation
the doctor they gave me
is a really perfect fit for me and my
medical needs
there's no risk no commitment to get
started just click the link right
underneath this video